in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Judy is
with us hi Judy how are you hi Dave I'm
fine how are you I am better than I
deserve
yay it's an honor to have you welcome
welcome where do you live
I live in New Jersey but work 18 miles
outside of New York City so I lived
there okay very cool welcome to
Nashville
thank you it's a bit of a halt you catch
a good flight down here yes I got here
at 8 a.m. is pretty early but I'm here
for this and business and some pleasure
at the end absolutely make sure you get
to see Nashville yes it's a happening
place yeah cool beans cool so you're
here to do your debt-free scream how
much of you paid off am I paid off about
a hundred and eight thousand dollars Wow
yes during the last six years there any
six years yeah okay making what kind of
money during that time I started at
50,000 and now I'm over a hundred but I
don't want to get too specific because I
have lots of you know friends listening
good okay and what do you do for a
living I make sure your money is safe
and your bankers aren't corrupt I work
for the federal government I feel better
already
good okay so a hundred and eight
thousand what kind of debt I made a
really bad financial decision you know
six years back I bought a house that I
couldn't afford it's a second house and
I over leveraged myself so a lot of the
debt went to a home equity home equity
line of craziness that I used to
purchase that second house and I had
owed Home Depot my mom two credit cards
it was just it was a it was a big mess
and so I felt overwhelmed by the debt
and I ended up going to the library and
looking up all these just looking for
something that talked about personal
wealth and wealth building and finances
and then I came across her audiobook and
I listened to it and I put it in and you
were there yelling at me telling me that
the reason I'm in this financial mess is
because of me you know I I did this it's
my fault so that was a huge wake-up call
for me and I ended up finding out about
your show and listening to it and then
at my church they offered Financial
Peace University and
uh it just continued on from there got
serious you just got sucked into the
portal didn't you yeah I drank the
kool-aid that's cool that's good it was
awesome so how long ago did you go
through Financial Peace University oh my
that was 2010 I believed yes so a six
year walk is a long walk there was
Murphy's and stupid tax along the way
and what was the best year of debt
reduction this was last year last year
I'll tell you your v was tough and it
was painful it was hard because I was
tired of eating bologna sandwiches I was
tired of not being able to go on
vacation and all my all the money was
going to the bills but at the same time
something got birth that this
experienced birth and me determination
and and perseverance and American grit
and just just a will to do better and be
something better and know that I can you
know overcome this so I must say that
God is a God of second and third and
fourth chances and he came alongside of
me while I was doing this and he blessed
it because he saw how serious I was
about it
and I just want to give a special shout
out to my financial accountability
partner Nicole she was there with me for
years we did the budget mm-hmm every
month got together we did a post-mortem
as to what happened that month before
and then we were reviewing and
challenging each other but what we're
going to do in the next month and you
know it was we were in each other's
faces we were just reminding each other
that why are we doing this why is it
important when what our life is going to
look like after we paid off all the
debts so so in the fifth year mm-hmm
that was tough yeah when things were
birthed yes determination
Ritt American grit American grit mm-hmm
was when that stuff was birthed was it
because you could barely see a flicker
at the end of the tunnel that there was
a light in the tunnel was it like hope
they kicked some of that in or was it
you just leaned into it so hard that you
just weren't going to stop which was it
I think I saw that even
though it was challenging I saw
promotions that came along that you know
the hard work ended up giving me the
promotion and God saying okay I see what
you're doing here's some more money to
get yourself out of this hole that you
dug yourself in so your five was
challenging but at the same time there
were gifts given in between so it's it
Rhian spired me to keep going and
realize I'm not that far I'm almost done
yeah that that part right there so
there's something about when you can see
the finish line even if it's way out
there you can see it mm-hmm you can get
there yeah it's like there's a light at
the end of tunnel and it's not an
oncoming train when that clicks grit
does kick in determination does kick in
because I've got this theory even with
me when it happened to me that that that
hope is somehow tied into that equation
mm-hmm yes that went you know that grit
and hope our brother and sister somehow
yes that they work together I don't
think grid is just you grind it out have
no idea if it's going to work you know
there's something about grit that has
hope mixed into it I don't know what the
recipe is two parts one three parts the
other however it works you're mixed into
it too of course because it was and I
really want to thank you and your team
because you guys are awesome and you
gave me the roadmap you you gave me the
guidance through listening to Uncle Dave
on the podcast every day and you just
telling telling us and encouraging us
what to do and we're just I'm just
thankful and you really are doing great
work here so thank you so much I do
appreciate that it's part of that
equation do though that you've got
somebody speaking over you that that's
doing that I mean you and I hadn't met
until today and yet I'll always be your
Uncle Dave and I'll be honored to do
that so but you know sooner do we grab
all day for some of y'all but anyway but
the you know we'll move along on that
but yeah there's something mixed in
there that causes people I think these
debt-free screams do that for people
yeah oh yeah yeah that gal I mean she's
up there in New York City where the
expenses are high you know and she's
fighting and she's she's single and
she's doing this I can relate to her and
and you know and I couldn't relate to
those other people but that one there
man you know and that's there's
something about this that does all of it
there's a community forming around
whole thing across the nation with the
podcast and the YouTube channel and all
that stuff and it's true date because uh
you know we all make mistakes we all
want do-overs and and I just want people
to know that if you made a really bad
financial decision you can recover
because you know I never thought six
years ago when I started this and I saw
my salary then I'm like well how's this
going to happen how's this going to work
and then six years later my salaries
more than doubled so I was I I really am
amazed about the program and then died
coming alongside and just making
everything move in the right direction
so how are you uh over 21 ah
you're sensitive about numbers aren't
you you're not that you off the air do
you're not that all you're not that all
you're a youngster okay alright whatever
all right
that's incredible what a great story
Judy thank you so much to you and I do
feel better if you're watching over I am
Sarah if you're watching over the the
bureaucrats up there and make sure
they're behaving you've actually got a
thing past past intellect it's now
called wisdom
thank you yes very cool good for you hey
Judy in New York City area a hundred and
eight thousand dollars paid off in six
years
making fifty two now over double that
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen one two three I'm free
well done well done